[音楽]
[拍手]
r
今日今回は皆さん
ファイロ男の子の話をしたいと思います
ための名前
2女の名前は良いです
英語は市民チェーンちゃってます
社交的でないからといってもです
大部分はいつもみんなのはないんです
リーダーズ牡丹の額です
リーグは星の砂キーワー
彼は教室の種の場からもう3年な方に入っ
もう錆びた方に出ていきます
彼はないなお花さん
自分の上で保護しています
このゲームのビッグには共通点があるん
2人とも安永がなくなるのがあったんです
そして1歳の南野が本当になってい
そして今この瞬間
きた人の願いをかけて
幸せ者ときて皆様の前に立っています
塩とビーフの頭にはどちらもクロス通りです
今日は皆さんこの円墳とピンクなら
多くの学んだけど
自分の顔見ちゃうなというふうについてお話しできればと思います
僕は一切のままでー
注文系として別名前を持っていません
家が関係者から外なぁ
周りのいざな学校なが車が違っていました
そして周りのみんな
当たり前のように関することは
自分にとっているものではありません
落としたのおせちも二子様です
僕はまた違うに後ろめたさの恐れを感じるようになりません
にゃっ
自分は可能口が運営で他人は自分に蓋を開いくれることはないと思いと基本を1本よう
になりました
マンの支えの増加やポイントにかどうにかもつようになりん
この音楽ように皆さん
そして学校に行くのを願うファンをもっと泣く子もありました
そのまま褒美の7校という
いわゆる日本のはここに磨きましたん
つまりも彼であったらいい
海神店を持ち話だ同級生夏でした
小学校59セントアップはコミュケーションございますよ
ただ今回は若くなることができましたん
自分の小学校生の傾向じゃない同級生のマンチで混乱を見ましたん
今までも2校で自信のない自分を当てて新しい自民だろう
今度は活動的でお洒落になることで周りから
宗男さんがように頑張りません
他人から釣果を言うことで
事業の8連勝としましたん
いろいろなことを考えていろんな賞運転
やらないんですがでいわゆるこの出てきましたん
構成新しい人間になったので僕は
加工北五百年からでした
新しい自分になりダメでした
しかしいくらパン無毛
この中にある後ろは誰も買わなくなることはありませんでした
ん
吉野にラッパで頑張ってる自分はうざいの自明なんじゃないか
本当の締めは昔のように方向で支払って
はずない存在なんじゃないかなぁ
そういう自分の中の英軍の b 君も広がるなくに
富士見ヶ口に合ったん
僕はぶつけないうつけのもないかも鈍化も環境もましたん
精神を組み合わせればでぜひらすごくが2らはしません
もう自分の殻を一生性はないのかやポイントして
感じることはない
僕は友人月に
水母の小学校際についてかかることを始めました
僕のを見つめるを確保あるいはは新車の言葉で受け止めてくれました
そして彼は言葉を借りて女を引っ張るも見えない自分の小学校ん経験の
ドーン株価過ごすぞ5月はもう朝
送られてきたのは
僕たちは負担の方法で自分を評価しているということです
一つ目は結果をベースをさん氷河です
この考えをするときホンダ例えば勉強ができるのは僕は大丈夫
冬用
自分を肯定するさんられるのゲームを引き起こします
目標山西省2首の2つが虫ピンの肩を掴みます
深いコクが来年までに英語試験意見をうかがいましょう
の木僕は来年本英語歴の旅自分をイメージして辛坊でしまう
そして
今は2分彼の好きなようなんだ
数百個目やつなんです
もらうことだものの考え方を今回握らず方に集まっています
ダメらの自分洋画家志望
ダメだと自分を比べて10分以上が目指せ
振り返って水面から言うとこの交代に立ち登校していたよって言ってみましたん
すごいと思いはないのほうがいいんじゃない
それがないんでバ
自分の大きなないし共感できない
ずっとん皆さん
そしてさんにとって売りがは未熟な一年を
ずっと心サイトを持っていました
スーパー三和小学校際の pa です
二巻
いくら高価よ海への反応も
自分はこういったものは中10位以内
僕はそんなふうに悩むばかりでした
まりこがビラの
そして皆様に会えないのはいい
条件脱毛の方にすることの大切さです
自分あり体大丈夫何があっても大丈夫思いのなことです
無理に回もはに入ったり
[音楽]
女だったりするからトーン
ずうがポイント大ぞと確信できる思うのです
何か完璧な新しい地図を生み出して今もすごい姫さんに
そう考えを通しません
この無象県王宮を行ったので
黒子ゲーでは少しだけなんかさ
自分が梅の実にどうするの水異なる
自分のやりたいこともできるようになりません
他人の人間の自分のは利用に関して
1暴発がないと悩むものを少なくなりましたさ
+神
自分は無条件放映するのは簡単ではありません
それでも自分の嫌いなところ一つ一つ小さくして
自分を素直にんぐの渡部必要があります
僕の場合小学校際の経験が自分にとって思いでした
雇用化をはに入って昔は昔今は今
と契約転換しました
を2つの人間は退屈するかによって日々変化しています
学校の先生のラーという自分は東急線を取らずには
タイプが使っています
今度は中学校以来ミラー
池を埋めん
辛い合わせるとなる仲間とで破られましたん
カメラ固定している過程で自分のラーメンが変化センター
だから小学校時代の自分に
暗い本
長官がようにしています
桜花が人は今月分のヨガのことを考えるに
て蹴っていると思いますん
それが違ったことで自分で取りに行かないことが居る事は居るかもいません
自分じゃないような感じみたい
いうかもの十大大冒険
制裁には不条件の方デー
この2つを支えてますよなるほどが
でバランスを材料になるのか
これは簡単じゃないと思います
現代社会は3巻緊張5歳の期間には触れていません
就職面接に大学二名
婚活の一条はラベリングの機械でいっぱいです
こう叫んだ車間 a
左が目標を達成するために
今も頭を否定するかもあまり必要かもしれません
スタッフというの
普通な生きていくということも存在の御寺ならに
者たちは極刑必要があります
ピンクらーずなんともその
いくら増加がやなんですね
梅田乗って異性企業の自分でおいたいん
僕の人生はあなたがなぜならないん
本当の心がには英軍の言い分という
隊の任命があります
テープのきっぽくの夢当選もエンジンが濡れる
いうわーーー
どんなになれるんだろうと思う
ドラムやるだけ
自分は裏買って行ってくればいいんだみんな
教えて皆さん
a 君とリーグは皆様ここの中にもいるかもしれません
時にはスナッピーなように風船とのあるかもしれません
それでも
自分女デー
ある今の
これは本の挑戦でもあります
皆さんも一緒に歩いていきましょう
ありがとうございません
[拍手]